ah dude nice right good for the morale
hoju morale great good in 203 they go on
a hunting trip to Hungary the
centerpiece of the episode is this and
sort of nightmarish dinner that Logan
hosts do our top team I was lit inspired
by reading about Stalin would have these
long dinner drinking parties where
sometimes he would drink water and get
his , SARS and
marshals to drink alcohol and then he'd
used their indiscretions against them
later
drink they had the flavor of those
dinner parties and the humiliations hit
me tact yes sit on the floor seriously
that's a game bore on the floor I really
I feel get down the actual or on the
floor just came from thinking about the
context they were in and sort of thing
that might occur to him right for your
sausages piggy I quite that feeling of a
powerful man unhinged Oh spoke to pounce
on Tom and Gregg crucial moment when Tom
he maybe could get some money in the
bank by selling him out doesn't hey
crawl in a circle and close your eyes
I don't think it's definitive it hasn't
Tom hasn't changed into a into a good
guy it just seemed to us true you know
people have different sides to them in
Tom for whatever reason had enough
regard for Greg that he he didn't want
to do it in
how was it it was pretty uh pretty tough
[ __ ] and Tom it's complicated
how is your weekend me anything to
report yeah he found out on his wedding
night that she wasn't really super keen
on a monogamous relationship
and that with his tough do you wanna
know you maybe later
there is a bond in that relationship I
think of like sexual connection and
intellectual and they have a bunch of
different ways that they do connect and
so it's not a it's not a dead
relationship even if it's a quite a
troubled one
[Music]
you